JUNICHI MONMA: Hello, everyone.
So my name is Junichi Monma.
So head of with Android
Partner Engineering in Japan.
So today I wanted to
introduce that robot
and so that is a tightly
integrated with the Android, so
and also the Google Play and
the Google Mobile Services.
And also introduced
another new SDK
that is enabling
to the developer
to making the application.
So supporting to these
systems and also that
are Android, so
welcome to the Pepper
to joining to the
Android family today.
So Laurent from the
SoftBank Robotics.
So he will be explain more
detail about the SDK today,
and also write programming
for that Pepper for you guys.
And then Pepper, of course,
assist to the Laurent
in this session.
So Laurent, please come in.
LAURENT LEC: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello, everyone.
I'm Laurent, software
director at SoftBank Robotics,
and I'm very thrilled
to be here today at I/O.
And we even brought some
company as I know some of you
have noticed earlier.
So this is Pepper.
He's a humanoid robot
designed by SoftBank Robotics,
and he's one of the first
mass-produced robots
to serve as a
emotional companion.
And the good news is it's
coming to the US this year.
So we are happy to start
supporting the developer
community.
But maybe we can let him
explain more about himself.
PEPPER: Hi there, everybody.
I'm Pepper.
It's an honor to be
here as a speaker
at Google I/O. We have
a great show for you.
I hope you're excited.
Are you guys ready?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
OK, guys, take a break.
I'll take things from here.
LAURENT LEC: So this
was a short dance
to introduce you to the
capabilities of Pepper
and hopefully to
get you more excited
about what we have
to show today.
So for the past
couple of months,
we have been working on
an Android SDK for Pepper.
This is not the
first SDK we write,
because we've been working on
robots for more than 10 years
now.
But we thought
and we wonder what
would be the best robotics SDK.
What would make
robots as accessible
as any other devices, such
as tablets and smartphones?
And basically, today we want
to share our conclusions
about this and we want to
show you how simple robotics
development can be for anybody.
So as you may have already
guessed, our SDK for Pepper
is an Android Studio plugin.
It is already available.
You can download it.
It's online.
And basically, you can keep the
same tools and the same habits
you have, because
we basically kept--
we want to get the original
Android Studio flow,
because we know you
are familiar with it
and this is something
that we really wanted--
we didn't want to change it.
So what we did is
merely adding tools
to the existing environment.
Tools for robots.
Basically, doing
your application
is exactly the same
way, but we also
provide APIs so that, of course,
you can make the robot move.
You can make it talk.
You can make it interact.
You should see what you
would expect from an SDK,
but more interesting
tools, such as animations.
So you can use
preexisting animations
that we provide with the SDK and
you can also create your own.
We will get to that later.
And we also provide
a chat editor,
so that you can script
very simple interactions
with the robot, which
is voice-commanded.
And last but not least, the SDK
also provide a simulated robot,
so that even if you don't have
a robot, which is probably
already the case,
you can already
start developing your own
robotics applications.
And for the rest,
it is the same.
So once your
application is ready,
you can create your PKG
as usual and maybe even
publish them on the Play Store.
So I have to say, we don't
have so many slides today,
because what I really want to
show you is the SDK itself.
So on the left side--
you already know
this-- it's Android Studio.
And in the upper right corner,
you see Android Emulator,
and the last item
is the robot view.
So the robot view is
basically a simulated Pepper.
And if you install the plugin
for Android Studio, which
would look something like
this, automatically you
will have new features
added to Android Studio
to be used with
Pepper, such as, you
will notice that there are
new buttons on the second line
of the toolbar here.
So the first one
is just my FD SDK,
because you can update
them with normal things.
And second one is
to, as I said-- oops.
It's OK, I can restart it--
to start the emulator, which
will automatically start
the tablet emulator,
but also the simulated robot.
So we have to wait a little bit.
And I said earlier that we
support animation and also
chat files, and these are
accessible as normal Android
resources using
this little menu.
So all the tools we are
providing out there.
And so you can create
robot application.
You can add a animation
timeline that we show you
a little bit later.
You can create chat topics
or chat files and also
import animations,
because we already
provide a library with very
nice and useful animations.
So maybe you can start
with a little coding.
What we wanted to do also is not
to provide the same usual way
APIs work with
service and modules.
Our design is based on actions.
So what is an action?
An action is more like a task
that you can start and stop,
and this is-- it really
correspond to something
the robot is doing.
So for instance, a window
draws widgets and a robot
would perform actions.
So when you create a task,
you can set some parameters
and then execute the task.
And of course, you can
do it synchronously
or asynchronously, which is
very important for Android.
And getting called back
when the action is finished,
things like that.
So if I take a very
simple example, which
would be to make the
robot say something,
it would look like
creating a Say object
and then simply run
it with the parameter.
So for instance, this wouldn't
be [? LOR ?] but [? LOIO. ?]
Now, I don't want to spend
so much time compiling
and deploying so we have
already preinstalled
the sample on the robot.
So what you see on the
screen would exactly do this.
PEPPER: Hello, I/O.
LAURENT LEC: Very simple.
And the robot talks.
So I said that we
provide motors,
because running an
application is not only
about writing code for robots.
You have to care about
a lot of other things,
such as using the hardware,
because we have so many motors
that you really want the
robot to do something.
This is why we also
have animations.
And our SDK allows you to
use preexisting animations
that our company is doing.
So we provide some
more categories.
Let's say for instance,
action, animals,
because it will come back
later in the presentation.
Let's say, a gorilla animation.
So this animation-- you
can see the preview--
you can exactly take
it and import it
into your project just as
any normal Android resource.
Let me show you.
So we're happy with this
animation, we select it,
and this is automatically
imported into the resources.
You will see that the
code window has changed
to look like you are
probably familiar with that,
this is more like
a key frame setup,
because you can edit those
animations from the plugin.
So if you look quickly, here we
have the values of the joints,
so like the different motors,
and we have the positions
for the shoulders.
And so we can change
it and sometimes it's
not enough to just
set the angles,
because that could make
very jerky animations.
So we also provide
a more advanced mode
for the people who really want
to fine-tune the animations,
which look like this.
So basically it's
a nice way to set
all the tangents
of the animations
and to control how
the movement would--
how you would get from
position A to position B.
So if I preview the
animation on the emulator,
you can see the robot
is doing something.
And what I didn't
mention earlier
is you can also connect
directly to a physical robot.
It's just the same.
So if I preview the
animation, let's say,
I want to change the position
of like the elbow roll,
and you will see like the
difference in sense and feel.
Well, it's not so
obvious, but you
can see that the right
elbow of the robot
is moving in a different way.
So all this can be easily
changed and customized.
And this is basically
how we write the dancing
that you've seen at
the beginning, which
is more of a professional
way of doing animations.
But again, if you
just want to have
an application with a
robot doing the gorilla,
you just use the
preexisting animations.
Let me show you a
couple other ones.
So maybe animals are
not so interesting,
but when you write
applications and you
want to have
interaction with a user,
you want to use expressions
like affirmation or exclamation.
[INAUDIBLE]
You can have more complicated
stuff like emotions.
So if he's look at positive,
you know, like blowing kisses,
because it's a nice application.
Yeah, so this is
it for animations.
And again, this is
very important when
you write a robotic
application, because you
don't want only to display
things on the tablets.
You also want to have a
robot that moves and that can
do a lot more things than
just a normal device.
Then it's also nice if you
can talk with your robot.
So we've seen that yesterday
during the keynote.
Vocal command is so
important and interesting.
So we also provide the way
to write your own sequence,
like script, little
interactions with the robot
that we call chat files.
So I have a chat files
already prepared here.
So I will not go into the
details of the grammar,
but basically you
can write questions.
And depending on the
answer to that question,
react differently.
And I will show you that
on the emulator, which also
preinstalled the application.
And let's say you're
working on the plane
or on the train or
whatever and you just
want to test what you're doing,
we provide dialogue view.
So here you can type
anything and directly
discuss with your robot.
This is exactly
the same thing that
would happen if you talk to it.
It's just that you are feeding
the text through the emulator.
So for instance, hi.
Do you like comics?
Yes.
Whose side are you on,
Steve Rogers or Tony Stark?
That is Steve.
And the robot is turning me.
So this quick example
show you that it's
very easy to write
your own sequences
and it can be very
easy like this,
but you can quickly get to
more complicated examples
and also have
reactions tied to that,
so starting things and all,
which is more interesting
than just talking.
So all those tools,
again, are directly
integrated into Android Studio.
You don't have to do anything
else, just installing
the plugin and using them.
So I showed you the
things separately.
Let's look at the more
complicated example.
But I don't really want
to spoil what he will do,
so let's first start with the
application, which is already
on the robot, and then I will
show you how it's written.
Demo I/O.
PEPPER: This is my
waving animation.
Watch me move and
speak at the same time.
LAURENT LEC: So
let's show it again.
PEPPER: This is my
waving animation.
LAURENT LEC: So
starting an animation.
Making the robot talk.
PEPPER: Watch me move and
speak at the same time.
LAURENT LEC: Then let's make
him move and hopefully not fall.
PEPPER: I will sing a joke.
LAURENT LEC: And I
touch the screen.
[ELEPHANT TRUMPETING]
And you have the first
robotics-- elephant robotics
joke ever.
So all this, which is
already looks pretty cool.
I'm sure you really want
to try it and show it
to people how you already
have more complex ideas.
I want to show you the
code, because it's not
so complicated.
Here.
So are we not going into more
details about the on create.
We create the activity and we
carried or saw it different,
right, because for a few
statements, you will see,
I want to block and we don't
want to stop the UI thread.
So create a new
thread and you can
see there is a start method,
which is just underneath, which
we call the wave method
and the move method.
Let's look at the code of those.
So for the wave, the robot
was saying, "This is my waving
animation" and then waving.
So two lines to
make the robot talk.
You create a say action
and then you just
run it with the
appropriate parameters.
And then the animation, what
we did first was actually
to import the animation,
the elephant animation,
into the resource
of the project.
And once it's done, we can just
start the animation using run.
So yeah, maybe a
more details, you
can see the line is
Hello animation, I
import the-- I create an
animation from the resource
Hello A001.
And then I can just
run the animate
with the Hello animation.
So if you want to start
a different animation,
we just need to make another
animation from resources
and just play it.
Now, to get a robot to move,
it's a bit more complicated,
but hopefully we provide
better [INAUDIBLE] still a bit
[INAUDIBLE].
What is important is that
the robot is in a 3D world.
The robot is moving
and you're also moving,
so you need to get a good
sense of where you are
and where you go and
where things are.
This is why we have
what we call frames.
So you have the robot
frame, it's basically
is where the robot
is, and then you also
have to define where
you want to go.
So that's why you can
see the few lines of math
to get moving correct,
but again, hopefully we
want to make it simpler soon.
So we've just said everything
we want to do and set the target
frame and simply create a go
to object here and then run it,
and the robot will move
one meter, so roughly.
And then, I don't know
if you remember, but I
touched the screen and he
played elephant animation
and play sound.
So this is basically,
we have a call back
when I touch the picture.
And so you're probably already
familiar with the audio manager
to just get the
sound and play it.
And the animation again,
is a wave something,
you just create the
animation from the resources
and then you just play it.
So that's it.
Like very few lines if you
remove all the boilerplate
code, you can start doing
things that are very interesting
and you don't even need to know
a lot about the robot itself.
You just use the APIs, because
this is what we want you to do.
We want to extract
everything on the robot side,
because it's a
very complex thing.
It's not only a display,
there are many things
to synchronize and resources.
We don't want to
have confliction,
these kind of things,
and this is basically
our job to give
you the right API
so that you don't have to care
about these kind of things.
So, yeah, I think it's about
like 70 lines or something
and we have a pretty
good animation.
So this is just an example
to show you about the SDK,
but I think it's
not very interesting
and it doesn't leave you a
good idea about-- not very
good ideas, but we
have better things
to show you that
we've been working on.
And we've prepared two very
interesting demos with Google
using Googie technologies and
we want to show you those.
And as Pepper would say,
it's better with a robot.
So we'll use the physical
robot instead of the emulator.
Can you come back?
[APPLAUSE]
JUNICHI MONMA: Thanks, Laurent.
So today we are going to
show that two another demos.
So first one is
showing the magic hand,
we call the magic hand.
So it's kind of a
gesture recognition.
So most of devices in the
mobile one, that is still using
that 2D dimensional display.
So biggest difference
between the mobile devices
are so this kind
of a robot, this
can be expressed at
any reaction by using
this three-dimensional things.
So that would be one of the
impressive integration for us.
So the other one is we are
going to show that [INAUDIBLE]
presence today then.
So Laurent, can you show us that
first one for that magic hand?
LAURENT LEC: Yes.
So we built a demo using tensile
flow that you're probably
familiar with.
And we wanted to use the sorry.
We wanted to use the 3D
sensor for the robot--
PEPPER: Starting Enchantment.
LAURENT LEC: --so we have
two 3D cameras here--
PEPPER: Please wait.
Let's see.
LAURENT LEC: --here,
and the robot
can get a good sense
of his environment
and detect [INAUDIBLE].
PEPPER: Please wait.
Let's see.
Just a second.
LAURENT LEC: And a
more cool example
would be what you will see.
PEPPER: I found it.
LAURENT LEC: So this
is not really a game,
but it's more like a proof of
concept using tensile flow--
PEPPER: I found this magic book.
LAURENT LEC: --and
the 3D camera.
PEPPER: It sure
looks [INAUDIBLE].
LAURENT LEC: The
idea is to detect--
PEPPER: Would you like
to learn some spells?
LAURENT LEC: --shape of my
hands, what gesture I'm doing.
PEPPER: For the
magic signs to work,
you need to first put me
under your control using
the spell starter sign.
The magic book says to hold
up your right hand towards me
just like on my chest display.
Hold it for three seconds.
LAURENT LEC: So the robot wants
me to do this for a few seconds
so that it's enchanted.
So I get that
control of the robot.
Doesn't see me.
PEPPER: Make sure you're
using your right hand
and holding it in front of you.
LAURENT LEC: Hello.
So it's supposed to see my hand
and detect the shape, but--
[WHOOP WHOOP SOUNDS]
PEPPER: Hello.
It worked.
The magic must be strong in you.
Let's see if you can cast
some higher level signs.
LAURENT LEC: I think
the robot [INAUDIBLE].
PEPPER: Next, try tilting your
hand to the right, like this.
LAURENT LEC: So
the robots now want
me to do something like this.
So--
PEPPER: Make sure you're
using your right hand
and holding it in front of you.
[ELECTRONIC SOUND EFFECT]
We did it.
Now, try the same sign
but to the opposite side.
LAURENT LEC: Like this.
PEPPER: Make sure you're
using your right hand
and holding it in front of you.
[ELECTRONIC SOUND EFFECT]
Amazing.
Maybe you should fix the Tower
of Italy, if you have time.
LAURENT LEC: OK, so we
see we have some issues
with [INAUDIBLE] cells
in this environment,
but you get the idea.
PEPPER: Wow, you're a
very talented wizard.
LAURENT LEC: Thank you.
PEPPER: I haven't seen hands
this magic since the last time
I visited my masseuse.
[LAUGHTER]
Let's see if you can master
some other magic signs.
First, put me under
your spell again
with a spell starter sign.
LAURENT LEC: So this is a
very interesting example,
because with like
very few things,
using tensile flow
and some learning,
you can have a very
interesting product
with applications in real life.
Because if we have
this, then we can easily
have things like Pepper
understanding sign languages,
for instance.
And maybe someday, because
right now it's probably
a bit difficult for
him, but we could also
have the robot talking back.
So it would support
a different class
of languages and translations,
which would be, I think,
pretty cool.
So yeah, this is
using tensile flow
and we also have another
very interesting example
using other technologies.
So I will show you.
PEPPER: Starting a
Pepper trio dance.
Please wait.
Let's see.
Just a second.
Oh, I found it.
LAURENT LEC: Ah,
wrong application.
Here's the dance.
PEPPER: Starting
Pepper telepresence.
LAURENT LEC: This is good?
JUNICHI MONMA: So there's
something the trouble then?
So next there is a
telepresence then
you may have already having
that Cardboard this time.
We are going to
use the Cardboard
demo with the Peppers.
Pepper has the
video and also that
another bunch of a
sensory in that robot
and we are using that
video and also the mic,
and they're also
sending to those data
to that mobile devices.
You can see that everything
that's through the Cardboard
are using that mobile
devices and Cardboard,
then if you are printing to
that paper to your house,
then you can remotely see
into that status of your house
and everything so through
their mobile networks.
LAURENT LEC: Here we go.
So we are using Cardboard
and basically taking
control of the robot.
So it's not a really
nice environment,
but what would be
great is actually
that when I'm speaking,
the sound also
comes out from the microphones.
So I could be [INAUDIBLE]
with my Cardboard.
So this is a very interesting
telepresence use case,
because now I feel like I'm the
robot, which is a bit weird.
And this is also-- this is
a very simple application.
We are just using Google
technologies and simply putting
things together, getting
the cameras of the robot,
and just using normal
Cardboard development.
JUNICHI MONMA: OK.
Thank you.
So this is quite new, and
then just before the I/O
then, sorry for that
some of the trouble.
So hopefully the [? USG ?]
making the more cool
application and then go
through the Google Play
and uploading to
the Google Play.
So that would be created
another ecosystem in the wall.
So you can-- so
Pepper will assist
your life and [INAUDIBLE]
your life, of course,
and that can be given
the more opportunity
to that the people to be using
these devices in the kiosk
devices, and also
that any assistance
for that [INAUDIBLE]
kind of devices.
That would be great
integration to this area.
So thank you for joining
to that this session,
and their hope you today
are making the application,
starting to the
application sometime soon,
and are ready to
that Google Play.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]